[Musik]
das podcast ist die blm unique so große
zweiter vorlesungen der benjamin
vorleser letzte woche erinnern sie sich
vielleicht hab ich versucht eine
allgemeine einführung zu geben
benehmen und die geschichte geschichte
der philosophie und benjamin obwohl ein
progressiver denker ist ist auch einer
der verwurzelt ist in vielfältigen pesto
historischen quellen und ursprüngen
heute würde ich mich einer dieser
quellen widmen nämlich der ideologie
theorie von karl marx das ist nämlich
prägend für den ganzen theoretischen
aufbau des aufsatzes des reproduktions
aufsatzes okay also was ist jetzt
ideologie und worum gibt und was ist
jetzt was ist dann die politische
dimension wie gesagt ursprünge ebenfalls
unmittelbar in den theorien von karl
marx und der erste gedanke bei der
ideologie ist die vorstellung der
ideologie das ist so falsches
bewusstsein
das ist das gerade möglichen glaubens
elemente oder abergläubischen elemente
beispielsweise auch in der religion die
dazu dienen leute zu blenden
also das ist kein neues problemen die
wir wissen die ganze problematik der
sozialen medien und der verbreitung von
fake news und so weiter das ist ein
aspekt dass man alles marx mal
vielleicht als als ideologie bezeichnet
hätte allerdings ich weiß nicht ob
glatte lügen zur ideologie
klassischerweise sind biologisch
falsches bewusstsein kein der inhalt des
falschen bewusstseins es nicht ist nicht
sind nicht direkte lügen sondern
verblendung zusammenhänge wo man nicht
adäquat im bilde ist über die
wirklichkeit seiner eigenen existenz
also dazu können sicherlich auch lügen
gehören aber so krass unwahr muss
ideologie nicht sein
gut aber ebenfalls ist der hintergrund
bei marx ist der gedanke dass zur
ideologie und damit zum falschen
bewusstsein höheren elemente wie nicht
nur religionen es ist die klassische
vorstellung eines marxens atheistischer
sicht ist die religion eine eindeutige
ein eindeutiges blindwerk nicht nur die
religion sondern eben auch die kunst
kunst ist oder wäre oder quasi so
tradiert kunst wäre etwas aus
marxistischer sich höchstens dem in der
freizeit was zu genießen und dabei auch
allerlei ideologische elemente
enthalten würden also marx oder
ebenfalls als ich glaube nicht dass
aufmerksames zutrifft aber die der
ansatz wäre aus als halter machen
christlicher sicht dass die kunst ja mit
vorsicht zu genießen ist und meistens
instrumentalisiert wird von den
herrschenden kräften um eben die
arbeiten der masse über die über seine
eigenen politischen interessen zu
täuschen
also das ist quasi der ansatz erst mal
mit die sind mit dieser diesem gedanken
der ideologie und wenn man das so
verfolgen würde ist das natürlich eine
klassische position findet man schon bei
platon in der politik wo plattform eben
auch zum ausdruck bringen dass die kunst
allenfalls ein abbild eines abbildes
eines tendenziell falschen abbildes ist
und da und dadurch umso mehr falsch und
umso mehr ein bereich ist wo man mit
vorsicht vorgehen muss ok also der
gedanke das ist der klassische ansatz
ist kunst ist blindwerk und deswegen
nicht kein würdiger gegenstand der
philosophie oder überhaupt der moral
oder sonst heißt also es ist etwas wie
auch horaz sagt es sind gefällige
süßigkeiten mit denen man bestenfalls
moralische lehrern verabreicht das ist
ein anderer klassischer ansatz also
etwas nebensächliches und nicht so
wichtig ist und bei marx eben auch
potenziell gefährlich weil dadurch
reaktionäre politische an
gefährlich der pax verpackt werden
okay nun bei marx oder mag der ist dass
theorie gerüst von marx ist trotzdem
muss man sich das anschauen weil wie
gesagt die diese struktur geht in die
debatte im zwanzigsten jahrhundert ein
und gerade auch bei benjamin übrigens
das habe ich schon erwähnt aber nochmal
im hintergrund der gedanke ja die kunst
ist ist ablehnt werk und unwahr und so
weiter dagegen hat man sich natürlich
auch ganz deutlich
gerade im 19 jahren darauf gelähmt
zunächst wohl bei in der romantik also
wenn man sich nur alles anschaut also
seine auffassung von kunst ist viel
positiver als als platons beispielsweise
oder die klassische auffassung und dann
noch viel deutlicher und philosophisch
aufgearbeiteter sozusagen bei nietzsche
wenn sie von ethel die arbeit geburt der
tragödie lesen dann wenn sie dort
aussehen also vermieter ist die kunst
nicht kein als bei klassischen
bewusstsein sondern ist mehr oder
weniger eine quintessenz des
bewusstseins überhaupt
deswegen dieser satz dass die welt nur
im sinne der kunden zu rechtfertigen ist
also der hintergrund ist auf der einen
seite die marxistische einstellung
wonach kunst allenfalls eine verpackung
von negativen politischen ansichten ist
auf der einen seite und auf der anderen
seite dann heranwachsens die vorstellung
ja kunst ist viel mehr als das ist
eigentlich prägend für die wagen der
welt überhaupt das als einführung in die
klassische stelle bei marx über die
ideologie kommt zur kritik der
politischen ökonomie im vorwort also die
quelle ist marx engels werke in band 13
seite 8 aus dem vorwort der arbeit zur
kritik der politischen ökonomie und das
heißt es bei marx in der klassischen
stelle wendet sich hier gewissermaßen
gegen weil hegel wie sie möglicherweise
wissen hegel theorie entwickelt das in
der geschichte es um geist geht um die
entwicklung von bah ist der geist
entwickelt sich fortwährend und dadurch
entstehen andere gesellschaftliche
formen also das ist schon quasi die
inspiration für magst mag sagt aber das
ist dann falsch rum
es ist nicht geil ist der
die historische entwicklung bedingt
sondern umgekehrt das ist die konkrete
historische entwicklung und den geist
bedingt klassischerweise dann heißt es
ist nicht das bewusstsein der menschen
dass ihr sein sondern umgekehrt ihr
gesellschaftliches sein dass ihr
bewusstsein bestimmt
also das ist diese berühmte auf die füße
stellen wovon häufig die rede ist
marxens anspruch ist ja hat es
gewissermaßen richtig gesehen das ist
dass es diese historischen entwicklungen
gibt und dass die welt sich verändert im
laufe der zeit aber hegel hat das als
irgendwas spirituelles gesehen oder
geistiges oder abstrakt ist oder was
auch immer
in wirklichkeit ist es aber so dass die
harten fakten der geschichte sich
entwickeln und darauf aufbauend
entstehen bewusstseins fahren und das
ist dann marx ins theorie dass von basis
und überbau das heißt dann da eben an
dieser in der gleich an der gleichen
stelle in der gesellschaftlichen
produktion ihres lebens gehen die
menschen bestimmt notwendige von ihrem
willen unabhängige verhältnisse ein
produktionsverhältnisse die einer
bestimmten entwicklungsstufe ihre
materiellen produktivkräfte entsprechen
okay was heißt das jetzt alles die
materiellen produktivkräfte bei marx
sind die organisations techniken die die
moderne welt ermöglichen und diese
organisiert weiteres mal auf materie
materiellen produktivkräfte
also die materiellen produktivkräfte
sind alles was dazu führt dass der
mensch also heutzutage ein industrie
eine industriegesellschaft aufbauen kann
das wären wichtig natürlich ist ist
wichtig die die die physische
technologie also dampfmaschinen und und
was sonst noch alles also dass die die
industrielle produktion ermöglicht auf
technischer ebene aber genauso wie ich
dich oder gegebenfalls noch wichtiger
sind die gesellschaftlichen organisation
formen und das sind zunächst mal
kapitalbildung also die möglichkeit dass
sich arbeit oder die früchte der arbeit
anfangen also kapitalist angehäufte
arbeit und das ist ich meine wenn ich
jetzt die bank habe oder oder irgendwas
das ist etwas was meine arbeit ja
normalerweise also meine arbeit
darstellt aber auf eine transferiert
bahre art und weise es liegt aber ich
kanns abruf und ich muss dann nicht
jedes mal also jedes mal wenn ich also
das bild wie er in einer primitiven
gesellschaft ich brauche keine an auch
ein neues hemd oder irgendwas in der
primitiven gesellschaft muss ich da raus
gehen
wie ein hemd herstellen oder im ende ein
tier töten und dann mit dem fell
bekleiden oder irgendwas also dass sich
so quasi dass die primitive situation
ist es bedürfnisse immer nur unmittelbar
durch eine direkte zeitgleiche tätigkeit
gedeckt werden können
ja das ist die ultimative analoge welt
aber sobald die möglichkeit von kapital
entsteht das heißt es meine arbeit
gestapelt angehäuft angespart werden
kann
dann verwandelt sich meine ganze
tätigkeit das führt zu allerlei
möglichkeiten die ich vorher nicht hatte
beispielsweise ich muss in der
primitiven welt so jedenfalls die
natürlich ist das eine karikatur aber in
der primitiven welt wie gesagt ich muss
jedes mal wenn ihr was brauche muss ich
das dann direkt erledigen ich kann das
nicht irgendwie abrufen oder im laden
gehen und kaufen oder sonst war sondern
ich muss das tier schlachten oder was
auch immer diese unmittelbarkeit
verhindert dass aus meiner arbeit mehr
wird als das was ich jedes mal direkt
unternehmen aber natürlich wenn kapital
oder die kapitalbildung eigentlich ist
das noch kein kapital das ist nur geld
aber trotzdem
also wenn diese möglichkeit erst mal
entsteht dann kann ich also vorab
arbeiten und erst später die früchte
meiner arbeit ein löst also
typischerweise dann das anstatt jedes
mal meine unmittelbaren bedürfnisse
unmittelbar zu befriedigen arbeite ich
dann auch für andere leute spezialisiere
mich auf irgendetwas bin ich ein
schuhmacher oder keine ahnung was ich
mache dann deine schuhe mehr als ich
selber braucht also nicht meine
unmittelbaren bedürfnisse sondern auch
für andere und bekomme von denen also in
der primitiven gesellschaft würde ich
dann eine materielle gegenleistungen
also vom bäcker würde ich dann droht
bekommen
ich gebe ihnen schuhe er gibt mir das
primitive tauschwirtschaft also ein
bisschen mehr als nur unmittelbare
bedürfnis befriedigen durch mich selber
aber wenn man auch primitiv aber sobald
das geht sobald das geld gibt kann ich
quasi auf vorrat meine schuhe herstellen
und dann verkaufen was auch immer ich
dann erhalte ich eben nicht materielle
gegenleistungen sondern eben geld
also das ist ein höheres abstraktion
niveau und durch dieses abstraktion
niveau bildet sich dann also die
möglichkeit ein paar stufen weiter dass
ich auf der bank 10.000 euro liegen hat
und nicht nur ein haufen schuhe die ich
dann noch verkaufen was oder oder was
auch immer
ok also das ist der erste astra aktions
schritt der weiter abstraktion schritt
zum kapital ist die möglichkeit größere
von diesem geld zusammen auch von
anderen leuten also der kapitalist hat
nicht nur dass das geld das er selber
verdient hat sondern er hat auch das
geld anderer leute
der kapitalist ist einer der geld
einnimmt dann also heute würde man sagen
investoren und bildet damit kapital und
damit also sobald kapital gebildet wird
also in einer primitive oder auf einer
primitiven stufe verdiene ich genug geld
um meine mein werkzeug zu kaufen
vielleicht damit ich meine schuhe
herstellen kann aber nicht mehr als das
der kapitalist bündelt nicht nur ist die
früchte seiner eigenen arbeit sondern
auch die früchte der arbeit anderer
leute und dadurch entsteht kapital und
das ist viel mehr und viel mächtiger als
es nur die verdienste des einzelnen und
das wiederum ändert ebenfalls die ganze
situation das ist dir das gesetz heißt
es nochmal behandlung von quantität in
qualität also wenn ich genug von diesem
kapital haben oder wenn ich genug geld
habe dann verwandelt es sich in kapital
und kapital ist was anderes in dem sinne
dass ich dann viel mehr unternehmen kann
als als ich vorhin hätte unternehmen
können ich kann eine ganze industrie
aufbauen
also ich brauche dann nicht mehr meine
schuhe oder ich mit meinem azubi oder
und was schuhe herstellen sondern ich
kann etwas viel größeres eine ganze
schuhfabrik aufbauen weil ich eben das
kapital die früchte der arbeit von
anderen leuten ebenfalls einbringen kann
gut also wenn wir so weit sind dass ist
der markt wir haben also wir haben von
anfang an gewissermaßen haben wir einen
markt für die schuhe
haben wir einen markt für kapital das
ist eine höhere abstraktionsebene die
erste abstraktionsebene ich attackiere
von den gegenständen mit den schuhen auf
die ebene geld die zweite
abstraktionsebene ich alles da hier von
dem unmittelbaren entgelt in meiner
erzeugnisse auf das ansparen oder
anhäufen von geld überhaupt und das ist
ein kapital also zwei abstraktion stufen
mindestens gut das wiederum also was ist
jetzt die die neue qualität die daraus
entsteht die neue qualität ist dass ich
das die welt der arbeit sich verwandelt
und hier wird es das ist jetzt das eine
ist quasi eine begriffliche änderung mit
geld das zweite ist eine änderung die
die gesellschaftliche organisation
umwirft
das ist die entwicklung des arbeitsmarkt
ist also wir hatten schon ein markt für
gegenstände einmal für geld und jetzt
haben wir einen markt für arbeit und das
erfolgs in der form dass anstatt dass
leute sich beliebig vielleicht als
schumacher oder bäcker betätigen und
ihre erzeugnisse dann anbeten das machen
sie jetzt nicht mehr das ist quasi das
klassisch feudale handwerks muster jetzt
neues anders indem sie sich als
arbeitskräfte
ganz abstrakt auf dem arbeitsmarkt
anbieten müssen
der handwerker in der feudalen
gesellschaft oder in der primitive in
gesellschaft macht seine erzeugnisse und
verkauft und was auf dem markt erscheint
sind nur seine schule nicht er selbst
aber wenig kapital habe und dann brauche
ich arbeite und zwar viele wenn ich eine
industrie aufbauen
dann brauche ich einen markt ich kann
nicht einfach warten bis irgendwelche
leute kommen sagen ja ich kann ganz gut
was auch immer drechseln oder oder wolle
spinnen oder sonst was
das geht nicht ich dass ich muss nicht
davon darauf verlassen können dass es
einen markt gibt wo ich bestimmen kann
was ich brauche der käufer ist könig und
der käufer ist der kapitalist der
kapitalist kommt auf dem markt und kauft
ein
er kaufte natürlich rohmaterialien für
seine erzeugnisse ein und außerdem
kaufte er arbeitskräfte ein
und das ist eine verwandlung das ist
eine tief greifende so marx ebenfalls
eine tiefgreifende organisatorische
verwandlung der alten gesellschaftlichen
strukturen und das sind alles materielle
produktivkräfte also die materiellen
produktivkräfte für den industriell ist
in der jetzt schuhe herstellt sind
einerseits die technischen bedingungen
gebrauchtmaschinen mit dem er die dinge
herstellen kann
aber noch viel wichtiger sind die
organisatorischen bedingungen nämlich
kapitalmarkt also irgendwoher muss das
geld kriegen um sein
seine fabrik zu bauen keine also oder
fast keiner heutzutage beginnt
industrielle projekte ohne kapital
irgendwo einsamen zu müssen er geht zur
bank oder oder was auch immer
also das ist die andere vorbedingungen
an die wichtigste vorbedingungen von
allen jedenfalls so marx ist der
arbeitsmarkt und hier haben wir lauter
organisatorische sachen die die früher
die früher gar nicht gab
die maschinen sind standardisiert nach
din normen oder sie erzeugen auch nach
din norm die erzeugnisse die gegenstände
die hergestellt werden dann geprüft und
von was war was auch immer also alle
sind insofern gewissermaßen miteinander
austauschbar
es sind waren das ist die wahren wird
zeigt eine wahre erzeugt unmittelbare
güter also der schumacher der für eine
bestimmte person schuhe herstellt das
ist keine ware
das ist etwas besonderes für den
einzelnen käufer aber die schuhe die die
meisten von uns in den schulen kaufen
das ist wahr
aber davon gibt es tausende und
millionen an alle sind einander gleich
oder mit gewissen abstufen instrument
der größe oder was auch immer
oder aber es sind waren die
veränderungen von individuellen
erzeugnissen zu wahren ist ja etwas was
man ständig beobachten kann auch in der
neueren technologie also früher vor ein
paar jahren wenn man einen computer
kaufen wollte dann hat man sich das ding
einzeln zusammen basteln lassen und das
war dann gewissermaßen also ein
handwerkliches produkt
aber heutzutage werde das kein mensch
laufen ich kaufe man einfach bei aldi in
irgendeiner form
das sind die fahren ja also das ist die
standardisierung die standardisierung
betrifft auch den menschen weil der
mensch ist dann nur noch eine wahre und
tritt auf den arbeitsmarkt als etwas was
mit bestimmten austauschbaren
eigenschaften also der hat eine
ausbildung als irgendwas schumacher
bankkaufmann lehrer keine ahnung also
irgendeine bestimmte austauschbare
qualität die für alle anderen leute
ebenfalls auf der auf diesen
arbeitsmarkt gelten ja also das ist dann
noch eine weitere attraktion von
menschen wird abstrahiert auf
arbeitskraft der mensch ist kein mensch
mehr sondern eine arbeitskraft gut also
das sind jetzt die mod materiellen
produktivkräfte für marx so und das aber
im grunde ist also zunächst mal ist wie
gesagt dass es ist nicht das bewusstsein
der menschen dass ihr sein sondern
umgekehrt die gesellschaftliche sein
dass ihr bewusstsein bestimmt und das
gesellschaftliche sein der menschen wie
gesagt gehört zu den materiellen
produktivkräfte und das ist was das
bewusstsein des menschen als überbau
bestimmt also der überbau ist dann hier
oben
und das argument quasi gegen gegen hege
ist ja hätte irgendwie gedacht dass das
die philosophen oder die philosophen
königer hier oben könnten bestimmen wie
die welt sich entwickelt und das ist
dann die geschichte auf der bewusstseins
leben auf der bewussten ebene
nein sagst das ist eine illusion
eigentlich ist es andersrum
es kommt von unten also die basis hier
unten bestimmt den überbau und nämlich
das bewusstsein
okay aber und jetzt hier ist marxens
theorie der politischen veränderung so
zu sagen weil es so ist es die
materiellen produktivkräfte sich zuerst
entwickeln
und weil eine diskontinuität besteht
zwischen basis und überbau
das sind nicht dasselbe sondern es ist
nur dass hier oben das bewusstsein wird
beeinflusst determiniert von von der
basis ist aber nicht dass er es kann
immer wieder dazu kommen dass die die
art und weise wie die menschen übersicht
denken in widerspruch steht zu den
tatsächlichen gegebenheiten ihrer
gesellschaftlichen existenz und das ist
vor allem so bei dann wenn diese
gesellschaftlichen oder die materiellen
bedingungen sich rasch verändern weil
dann kommt der überbau nicht nach und
speziell in der heutigen situation oder
nein sagen wir mal so zu diesem material
produktivkräften gehören
nein anders herum er sitzt im überbau
gehören auch juristische also im it
markt sagt auch juristische und
politische und künstlerische und
religiöse elemente und aus den
juristischen elementen fließen schon
materielle bedingungen
ich meine das recht auch für marx ist
kann sein dass das recht quasi dem die
basis irgendwie reflektiert aber die
juristischen elemente sind ein versuch
des menschen auf der brust 1 ebene sich
mit dem mit dem mit der basis zu
arrangieren und in der bürgerlichen
gesellschaft oder überhaupt
funktionieren die juristischen elemente
so dass die eigentum definieren also die
juristischen elemente auf innerhalb der
basis über baustruktur das sind die
elemente die die eigentumsverhältnisse
definieren also die
eigentumsverhältnisse sind quasi ein
bisschen abseits
[Musik]
indem sie sich darauf beziehen es ist
ein bisschen so ein feedback
es sind die juristischen überlegungen
die die eigentumsverhältnisse definieren
die dann auf die materiellen
produktivkräfte einwirken
ok und jetzt der klassische punkt ist
für marx ist in dieser ganzen geschichte
also das ist das kapital entwickelt wird
und das ist dass es arbeitsmarkt und
pipapo gibt das ist alles in ordnung das
ist die modernität so machen wir es
heute und wenn wir es nicht tun würde
und dann hätten wir die ganzen an den
annehmlichkeiten bequemlichkeiten des
modernen und leben das hängt von der
industrie ab also soweit in ordnung
das ist okay marxist kein so anti
industrie vielleicht sollte er dass sein
aber es ist es nicht das problem ist
aber dass wir das diese produkt diese
immens kräftigen diese immens kräftigen
organisatorischen maßnahmen von dem
juristischen und politischen und
gewissermaßen künstlerischen usw
reflexionen falsch verarbeitet werden
insbesondere dadurch dass die
eigentumsverhältnisse falsch definiert
werden und marxens bild ist in der
bürgerlichen gesellschaft also in der
kapitalistischen gesellschaft bildet
sich eine ein bürgertum heraus quasi auf
dem modell des feudalen also in der
feudalen gesellschaftsstruktur hat man
dem herr
oder die einzelnen was die begriffe ich
weiß es nicht also sie wissen was ich
meine
mehr oder weniger versklavte arbeit land
wirtschaftlich alle einen dem lokalen
herrn zugeordnet also man braucht man
hat damals einen herrn gebraucht um das
ding überhaupt zu organisieren in der im
feudalismus das geht zu bruch in dem
während des übergangs vom feudalismus
zum modernen kapitalismus aber was aber
nicht abgeschafft wird ist die
vorstellung dass man eigentum an den
produktionsverhältnissen beibehält
das ist es in der verteilung
gesellschaft ist der herr eigentümer des
von grund und boden wurde wo seine seine
leute arbeiten und die vorstellung das
eigentum an den an den produktivkräften
irgendwie notwendig ist oder geboten
also diese juristische vorstellung setzt
sich fort auch und kapitalismus und die
eigentümer im kapitalismus sind dann
nicht mehr die
die aristokraten auf ihren burgen
wehranlagen sondern es sind es ist das
bürgertum also der bürger oder der
großbürger jedenfalls der kapitalist
übernimmt die vorstellung von früheren
zeiten die politische vorstellung dass
irgendeiner eigentümer ist sein muss von
den von den produktionsverhältnissen ja
und das ist der fehler
das ist ein organisatorischer fehler das
ist für marx nicht keine moralische
sache sondern es ist einfach schlechter
organisation war im hoch entwickelten
kapitalismus oder in diesen
produktionsverhältnissen hängt es von
alle von den arbeitern ab von der von
der zusammenarbeit derjenige der kräfte
die auf den arbeitsmarkt zusammen kommen
und dann für die industrie arbeiten
es hängt von deren koordinierung und
solidarität ab dass die fabrik überhaupt
funktioniert also eine fabrik ist ein
team und ein team ist etwas wo keine
unausgewogenen aber
eigentumsverhältnisse bestehen bleiben
dürfen
das ist im grunde marxens argument dass
die die ganze systematik des
kapitalismus so marx ich meine ob er das
heute sind andere frage aber der punkt
ist wo ist jetzt der widerspruch für
marx der widerspruch ist zwischen den
eigentumsverhältnissen nämlich
insbesondere der vorstellung dass ein
die produktionsverhältnisse im
privateigentum eines kapitalisten sich
befinden sollen und den wird mit den
tatsächlichen tagtäglichen
arbeitsbedingungen die unbedingt teams
erfordern
ja also das ist der widerspruch und in
dem sinne sagt marx ist kapitalismus
sein eigener toten
er kann so nicht bestehen bleiben weil
die gesellschaftlichen verhältnisse und
die eigentumsverhältnisse nicht
miteinander übereinstimmen
ok also das ist jetzt möglicherweise ist
ihnen das alles sehr vertraut aber wenn
nicht das ist nicht
grundvoraussetzung dafür dass man
benjamin versteht gutmann die frage ist
ist jetzt jetzt geht es um diesen weiter
die frage ist also wie das haben sie
gewissermaßen gemerkt in dem sinne dass
diese eigentlich fing bei club erzeugt
hier eigentumsverhältnisse die nicht zu
dem materiellen produktivkräfte gehören
und wichtiger sind als nur ein
bewusstseins eine bewusstseins
reflektion weil sie tatsächlich
einwirken auf die sein wirken auf und
konflikten mit den materialien
produktivkräften ja also es gibt es ist
nicht so auch bei marks es ist nicht so
dass das der mensch quasi oder gerade
bei marx ist es nicht so dass der
menschen passiv gefangen ist
im in seiner ideologie in seiner
verblendung also ist die religion ist
nicht typisch oder mars geht also wenn
man die religion als als quasi beispiel
eines einer negativ für marx einer
negativen eines negativen ideologischen
inhalten und das ist nicht so für alle
ideologischen aspekte insbesondere nicht
für das juristische weil das mit im
juristischen organisiert sich der mensch
in dieser feedback geschichte und wirkt
ein auch auf die materiellen
produktionsbedingungen okay das ist das
ist nicht die wirkung ist nicht nur von
unten nach oben sondern kommt auch
wieder runter und bestehen aus becken
und diese überlegung dass der menschen
nicht nur quasi opfer von irgendwelchen
mehr oder weniger physischen vorgängen
ist das ist etwas was gerade im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert wieder ganz
wichtig wird
ja ich meine im 19 jahrhundert marx mit
positiven rekord mit john stuart mill
mit diesen ganzen leuten die waren alle
alle hatten der vorstellung gab es gilt
halt die harte naturwissenschaft die
wirklichkeit ist halt das was da draußen
ist was der jeder mensch nicht wie der
mensch darüber denkt ist alles völlig
sekundär und
die brauchen nur harte fakten und dann
können wir entscheiden wie die welt
vorangeht und wozu sie welche ziele sie
anstrebt im zwanzigsten jahrhundert ist
dann ist das dann wieder ein bisschen
anders dann wieder doch zu den gedanken
naja irgendwie muss der geist der
vielgescholtene geist bei hegel doch
eine rolle spielen und nicht nur abglanz
des der basis sein und hier haben wir
dann die wichtige stufe ist ein versuch
hegel wieder ein bisschen zu importieren
und der entscheidende denker in diesem
zusammenhang ist georg lukacs lukac
schrieb 1923 dem sehr einflussreichen
text geschichte und klassenbewusstsein
geschichte und klassenbewusstsein
geschichte und klassenbewusstsein ist
ein marxistischer ansatz ein versuch
wieder zu klären
ja wie entwickelt sich die geschichte
was ist fortschritt wie kommen wir aus
also 323 direkt nach dem ersten
weltkrieg absoluter kulturpessimismus
überall starker umschwung zu allen
möglichen revolutionären
auch nationalistische bewegungen aber
bei lukac ist der frühe
literaturwissenschaftler war oder im bus
punkt dass so ein ungarisches lokal 23
kommt er dann zu einer philosophischen
marxistischen projekt das sich in dem
extrem einflussreichen text geschichte
und klassenbewusstsein zum seinen
ausdruck findet der punkt mit geschichte
und klassenbewusstsein ist dass diese
dichotomie gewissermaßen aufgehoben wird
weil in der geschichte entscheidend ist
nicht ein mehr oder weniger eine mehr
oder weniger glückliche reflexion im
bewusstsein über das hier sondern das
bewusstsein ist grundsätzlich geprägt
durch gesellschaftliche elemente und
diese gesellschaftlichen elemente ist
sind das was lukac als
klassenbewusstsein beschreibt und sein
slogan sozusagen ist dass die geschichte
kollektiv hergestellt wird und zwar
kollektiv von proletariats und du kannst
sagt das proletariat hier ist ein slogan
wie gesagt das proletariat ist das
subjekt der geschichte also subjekt in
dem sinne dass arbeitende herstellende
bewusstsein eine kollektivität dadurch
dass ein mensch mitglied des
proletariats ist ist er oder sie
bestandteil einer des historischen
fortschritt ist also wenn ich politiker
bin dann bin ich quasi zwangsläufig ein
revolutionär ohne dass ich darüber
nachdenke es braucht eigentlich kein
feedback das juristisch und so weiter
das kann er vergessen
alleine dass die eigenschaft ein
politiker zu sein führt zu dieser
progressivität dass das ist etwas was
insgesamt im 20ten in dem denn bei den
denkern des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
großen einfluss gehabt hat also wichtig
ist dass quasi alle elemente eben auch
die dieser über bauelemente dem
organisatorischen zugeschlagen werden
das ist man ist nicht mehr der freiheit
zurück hat nur gesagt nicht mehr am
arbeitsmarkt kapitalmarkt und so weiter
also daraus schließt alles sondern er
sagt die gesamte bewusstseins
einstellung eines politikers das ist das
maßgeblich und das umfasst auch alle
ideologischen erleben also das was marx
als als ideologisch relativieren würde
das ist bei lukas teil dieses dieser
identität als subjekt der geschichte
lukas und das subjekt der geschichte da
kommt man bei lucas muss man einfach
abwarten bis das subjekt der geschichte
quasi die ernte einfährt
da ist nicht mal also nicht um nicht
zwangsläufig eine revolution oder
irgendwas oder oder oder juristische
reformen oder oder ideologischer kampf
notwendig sondern weil es ist einfach
eine frage dass man abwartet weil die
das polit ariad wird zwangsläufig ist
das politische zwangsläufig erbe der
geschichte also es ist gewiss ein
gewisser eine gewisse passivität gut
also das ist quasi ein negativer aspekt
der positive aspekt und das ist jetzt
bei was bei benjamin 1 gegen ihn hat
lukas text gelesen und es ist es sehr es
eingearbeitet bei wenigem m und das
jetzt ist der punkt mit
mit seinem text die produktionsarbeit
für benjamin ist quasi dieses für dieses
aufheben der diskontinuität zwischen dem
überbau und der bassist dazu dass
ideologische oder nein eben nicht die
ideologische künstlerische techniken
auch teil der des unterbaus werden
benjamins fragestellung ist okay in dem
sind auch wieder klassisch marxistisch
wir können uns distanzieren von den
unmittelbaren organisatorischen
gegebenheiten aber unsere rolle also was
erforderlich ist genau wie bei marx ist
es wie ein sehen was diese materiellen
produktivkräfte eigentlich von uns
fordern also der der kapitalist
vielleicht weiß was vielleicht nicht
aber er versucht zu verhindern dass die
arbeit zwar verstehen was hier los ist
also wie die arbeitet das verstehen
würden dann würden sie sehen wir haben
das alles geschaffen
wir haben diese welt erzeugt durch unser
teamwork die tatsache dass die eigenen
die juristischen eigentumsverhältnisse
diese macht in den händen des
kapitalisten konzentrieren
das ist überhaupt nicht notwendig dafür
dass die materiellen produktivkräfte
produktiv arbeiten und das sieht das ist
jetzt magst das sieht die arbeiter ein
und infolgedessen irgendwann werden
diese widersprüche bewusst und dann
kommt die revolution oder irgend sowas
das ist etwas was bei lukac ein bisschen
verloren verloren geht weil der polit
aria wie gesagt ab wird automatisch die
ernte einfahren ohne ohne dass er
besonders darüber nachdenken müsste ok
gut also dass ist da geht etwas verloren
bei lukas bei benjamin kommt aber wieder
zurück war benjamin sagt zu diesen
materiellen produktivkräfte wenn ich ein
künstler bin oder wenn ich überhaupt
nicht kunst was zu tun habe gehören auch
die technischen und organisatorischen
bedingungen der kunst der zeugung also
darüber hatte mag sich keine gedanken
gemacht aber das ist wie benjamin ganz
wichtig der ansatz ist genau wie marx
überlegt hatte ja wie kann man korrekt
wahrheitsgemäß die die folgen unserer
neuen gesellschaftlichen techniken
erfasst also die techniken kapital und
arbeitsmarkt wie kann man am besten das
verstehen und dann was draus machen
benjamin stellt die gleiche frage auf so
etwas eben einem etwas anderen kontext
nämlich wie kann man die technischen und
sozialen bedingungen der grund der kunst
der neuen kunst war die kunst ändert
sich wie kann man diese neue neuen
bedingungen
der neuen kunst so reflektieren dass wir
ja zu einem revolutionären oder
befreienden im antikatholischen
bewusstsein kommen die gleiche frage wie
bei marx nur ein kleines bisschen
verschoben oder oder der begriff der der
der materiellen produktivkräfte dann
damit erweitert oder oder auf spezielle
auf die kunst angewandt ok und da hat
man natürlich die gleiche situation
wir haben in der kunst so benjamin quasi
ältere formen prägen bürgerliche formen
formen der kunst und vormann der
künstlerischen organisationen die älter
sind und dann haben wir die neuen und
die alten das ist jetzt die auratische
kunst die einmalige ritual bezogene
kunst also heiligenbilder und solche
sachen den typisch wären dafür dass
einmalige das museum museale kunst die
die bilder die einzigartig sind nur
einmal vorkommen und und betrachtet oder
konzentriert werden
das ist die alte form der kunst die
existiert weiterhin aber wir dürfen uns
von diesen alten formen nicht blenden
lassen es gibt dann auch die neuere
kunst und genau wie die neue die neueren
produktivkräfte ein neues bewusstsein
oder organisatorische mittel erfordern
so ist es auch mit der kunst die neuen
produktivkräfte in der kunden erfordern
ebenfalls neue organisation ist oder
rezeptions techniken
ok also das ist der ansatz das ist der
gedanke wie macht es ja
dafür ist wird die zeit ein bisschen
kurz aber das wichtigste ist nämlich
dass hier also ein beispiel sein
wichtigstes beispiel wie sie wissen wie
wir schon angesprochen hatten ist der
film der film weil der film in der
herstellung notgedrungen als
kapitalistisch könnte man schon sagen
meine filme kann man nur herstellen wenn
man das kapital hat und auch einen
arbeitsmarkt also nicht unbedingt für
die darsteller weise darsteller sind das
leute auf den arbeitsmarkt keine ahnung
ich weiß es nicht aber jedenfalls für
das ganze restliche team braucht man
eine arbeitsmarkt also kapital unserer
also das ist jetzt vielleicht weniger
wichtig in abschnitt 14 der ersten
version dass das kunstwerk aufsatz es
macht also ein paar bemerkung ich will
das jetzt nur überfliegen aber
beispielsweise sagte also was ist jetzt
die was ist jetzt die was sind jetzt
diese geänderten technischen bedingungen
und ein filmstar der film bietet einen
anblick wie vor wir vorher nie und
nirgends denkbar gewesen ist also für
das kunst was ist jetzt dieser anblick
und sein beispiel ist dann es gibt
keinen einzigen standpunkt mehr
also das heißt im film
die kamera nimmt immer wieder
unterschiedliche aspekte auf und der
cutter schließt sie dann zusammen aber
das ist so ein quasi eine krücke
künstliche konstruktion die vorher auch
nie möglich gewesen wäre also in der ja
sagt benjamin jedenfalls das ist das ist
er sagt seine evolutionäre natur das vom
film ist seine natur zweiter ordnung
sie ist ein ergebnis des schnitts das
heißt im film atelier ist die apparatur
derart tief in die wirklichkeit
eingedrungen dass die
einer vom fremdkörper der apparatur
freier aspekt das ergebnis einer eigenen
technischen prozedur ist also es ist die
montage diese technik der montage also
ob man jetzt unmittelbar von diesem
beispiel überzeugt ist oder nicht das
spielt jetzt keine große rolle aber wenn
jemand sucht nach elementen und es gibt
die sicherlich wo die neuere kunst hier
am beispiel des films strukturell
unterschiedlich ist von allen
vorangegangenen kunstgattungen ja und
diese veränderungen am end ist nicht nur
analog mit den änderungen in dem
materiellen produktivkräfte der
industrie oder oder oder der der
wirtschaft sondern ist auch ein teil das
ist der zweite der zweite punkt den er
macht also insofern auch politisch die
pumpen die kunst ist zwangsläufig
politisch sagt sagt benjamin
und das ist der zweite punkt den er dann
in abschnitt 15
von der ersten version bespricht und
wieder das ist zum beispiel dass sie
vielleicht akzeptieren oder vielleicht
auch nicht aber er sagt die der film
erfordert oder lädt ein zu einer
kollektiv rezeption
ja also der film der film findet statt
mit im kino mit vielen zuschauern jetzt
ist natürlich wieder jetzt mit netflix
und kohl wieder anders aber damals
jedenfalls das phänomen die zuschauer
strömen ins kino und betrachten und
schauen sich einen film an
das ist etwas was es vorher in der form
nicht geben konnte was er auch dass die
zuschauer in vielen kino ist überall im
land das sich denselben film anschauen
gleichzeitig das ist auch diese
kollektiv rezeption ein weiterer aspekt
auch davon dass es irgendwie sie wissen
also einiges mehr als das alles aber er
sagt wie gesagt ob wir dieses diesem
beispiel zustimmen würden oder nicht ist
eine andere frage aber für die
gesellschaftliche komponente der
produktions kräfte sagt er auch das
führt dazu oder kann dazu führen zu
dieser anderen art zu dieser andere art
der rezeption oder abwärts aktion
aufgenommen wird der film zum einen als
zerstreuung
das haben wir letzte woche ein bisschen
angesprochen und zum anderen kritisch
also der der der zuschauer eines films
setzt sich kritisch mit dem film
auseinander
auf der art und weise was er beispiel
also sein sein beispiel mit picasso oder
mit den surrealisten nicht mehr oder
nicht trauen würde quasi da der nicht
kunst
theoretiker schaut sich im museum ein
realistisches bild an
ich bin nicht meins würde er nicht
wissen wie damit umgehen möglicherweise
akzeptieren möglicherweise ablehnen aber
jedenfalls sich nicht engagieren
das ist anders mittel also mit dem film
sind die leute kritisch involviert also
sie finden es gut finde schlecht und
finden auch gründe dafür also das ist
eine einbeziehung was sind in der die
traditionellen kunstformen nicht möglich
ist oder jedenfalls nicht gepflegt wurde
ok also dass jetzt ein paar hinweise
darauf es worum es jetzt benjamin geht
in dieser geschichte also wie gesagt man
mag schon mal heutzutage sagen naja
benjamin idealisiert den film bisschen
aber ich meine eben war schon klar
damals mitte der dreißigerjahre das film
missbraucht und missbraucht wird
im negativen sinne ideologisch
ideologische zwecke
ob es jetzt leni riefenstahl ist oder
was er als grotesk filme betrag oder
sind die gut ist vergessen aber
jedenfalls so sentimentale filme die ja
die die kein politisches bewusstsein
erzeugen sein beispiel für etwas für
gute filme sind charlie chaplin weil das
war sie eine satirische distanz
gegenüber den politischen geschehen was
gerade bei knapp und sicherlich auch
stimmt der fall ist ok also das ist was
ich heute sagen wollte
gibt es fragen einwände